[Musique]
en fait on avait envie de partager
quelque chose de notre culture mais on
voulait que ce soit fait un autre façon
oui et non à la façon c'est souvent les
représentations autochtone ils sont
souvent faites par un regard non
autochtone tandis que là on voulait
imposer notre façon de le présenter un
élément de notre culture
et puis
quand on est dans des grandes
institutions comme les musées ça demande
beaucoup d'ouverture de leur parti pour
pouvoir recevoir une oeuvre comme la
nôtre un concept comme non donc on est
vraiment content que le musée des
beaux-arts et eu cette ouverture là
c'est une structure cylindrique avec des
perches de bois et puis c'est le couvert
de toiles de tente donc mais la
structure est pas fermée en se servant à
s'élever à 120
donc on rentre dans une salle où est ce
que la salle et les progrès et les
rondes pour nous autres importants là qu
on recense 7
cette circularité dans la pièce et puis
tout est noir le plancher noir et même
l'illustré si on veut pour donner un peu
l'idée c'est qu'on voulait faire perdre
ses repères aux as il ya cette
structure-là cylindrique avec les berges
de moi et notre le temps qui au centre
de cette pièce la circulaire donc les
gens peuvent circuler autour de cette
structure
et puis derrière ils vont voir une
ouverture
et puis en fait on invite les gens s'ils
veulent complètement vivre l'expérience
qu'on leur propose d'entrer dans cette
structure là où on y présente
des images des projections avec une
trame sonore aussi qui vient appuyer
pour les images pour faire vivre cette
expérience
[Musique]
pour la partie vidéo on a demandé à trop
modèle trois femmes autochtones de nous
prêter leur corps et visage pour
exprimer un peu ce que nous on voulait
at-il à travers nos propos on s'est
inspiré un peu de la forêt de la nature
on a mis une partie animale aussi on
voit un troupeau de caribous on voit les
corps pour une fois
des couleurs de l'animation aussi sorti
un chromatine pas de de ce qu'on est en
fait on a comme chacune autres partis de
dun qui ne représente que chacune à leur
façon et aussi pour la trame sonore
aussi on a beaucoup travaillé avec un
excellent travail donne un excellent
technicien en sont que nous a beaucoup
beaucoup aidé on a beaucoup à accepter
les idées sont pour comme que ce soit
quand fuir des constats colle un peu de
2 partout en fait pour exprimer niveau
sonore de notre conception
[Musique]
mais en fait pour nous c'était très
important que le titre soit dans nos
langues
on est des mecs et en innu on voulait
pas faire la traduction du titre aussi
donc
et puis l'autre monde c'est un sous
titre mais ce n'est pas la traduction du
titre qui tend notre came et puis il ya
une raison pour ça aussi c'est que dans
cette bleus on traite de quelque chose
de sacré et puis c'est comme on voulait
parler de quelque chose de notre culture
mais un autre façon on voulait éviter de
tomber dans une représentation plus être
nos logiques anthropologique comme on
voit souvent d'aller dans les musées
c'est souvent comme ça que le travail
des autochtones de l'artiste autochtone
et ai vu
et puis on voulait éviter cela en fait
on voulait simplement se donner le droit
de présenter quelque chose de notre
culture mais sans tout dévoiler
donc les autochtones qui vont voir notre
hub vont vont comprendre des choses
ceux qui sont pas autochtone qui ont le
même bagage culturel vont comprendre
autre chose aussi
mais fait on voulait que de se donner la
liberté de ne pas tout dévoiler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est ça c'est une façon de
reprendre s'accorder le droit d'être
fiers de nos lacets comme je pense c'est
vraiment la génération de nos parents
qui ont enclenché que ce processus mais
en disant en dénonçant parce que c'est
ça c'est lourd à porter mouais ça prend
du courage pour décidé de dénoncer
ouais parce que moi moi mais pareil en
fait les pensionnats mahbod mon père il
ya beaucoup vécu il ya grandi toute sa
génération main toute son adolescence au
pensionnat et il m'avait dit que plus
tard quand il y en a quand j'étais plus
vieil homme expliquant que c'est pas
c'est pas un ou deux portes et l'hymne
les sûr mais c'était à nous de montrer
qu'on peut aller dans le chemin de
guérison qui était très important pour
les voler il m'a encouragé tout le temps
dans tout ce que je faisais et il
voulait vraiment que notre génération la
génération de ses petits enfants et un
monde meilleur
une culture
plus riche plus heures émancipé la
commenter
[Musique]